[MUSIC PLAYING]
TU FAN: In the face of the
challenges of climate change,
and the depleting
natural resources,
humans exploring
physical solutions
to sustainable development
Green technology
can be one of the good options.
Since 2009, Malaysia has
been facilitating application
of green technology
through implementing
the national green
technology policy.
Over the centuries, humans have
tried to change the weather.
People have prayed and used
strategies to get more rain
and decrease the heat.
While we have not intentionally
tried to change the climate,
we have unintentionally
brought about changes
that are affecting us today.
Starting in the middle 1700s,
the Industrial Revolution
and the modern
agriculture practice
began to [INAUDIBLE] amount of
human-created carbon dioxide
emissions in the atmosphere.
Global carbon dioxide
emissions have
been rising at an annual average
of 2.7% during the past decade.
Countries all over the world
are used different techniques
to reduce carbon emissions.
These include establishing
power markets,
creating policy and legislation,
and a green technology.
My research has focused on
green technology in Malaysia,
but do you know what
green technology is?
Green technology is a
development and preparation
of products,
equipment, and systems
that conserve natural resources,
which minimizes and reduces
negative environmental
impact of human activities.
What makes a technology green?
It minimizes
environmental degradation.
It has zero or low
green gas emissions.
It is safe to use,
and it promotes
a healthy environmental
for all life forms.
It conserves energy
and natural resources.
It relies on
renewable resources.
Green technology is
not a new concept.
People have been trying to go
green for decades, including
using wave motors, wind
turbines, solar power
plants, and other
[INAUDIBLE] energy ideas.
In keeping with global
trends, Malaysia
has recently
proactively promoted
and adopt green technology.
In 2009, Malaysia
has established
the country's ministry of
energy, green technology,
and the water, also
called KeTTHa in Malay,
and adopted national
green technology policy.
The main goal is to
contribute to economic growth,
and to reduce Malaysia's
carbon footprint.
The objective of the
policy it to conduct
industrial and government
through supporting
in putting buildings,
green transportation,
renewable energy use,
waste and water management.
The most important
components of this policy
include setting up
institutions and launching
fiscal instruments.
Setting up institutions is a
key strategy in the policy.
Since green technology involves
many different sectors,
it is important to
have a structure that
involves all the relevant
stakeholders to ensure
consensus and support.
The national green technology
and climate change council
coordinates green
technology issues
between the ministries,
agencies, the private sector,
and other stakeholders
that implement policies,
in addition, the agencies
that assist and contribute
to development of
green technology,
like the Green
Technology Corporation.
As a focal point for green
technology development
in Malaysia, green
technology cooperation
provide facilities
and the services
in advisory, consultancy,
urban energy management,
and training.
Malaysia green technology
[INAUDIBLE] scheme
is a most important
fiscal instruments
to attract private entities
to use green technology.
This scheme is for both
the users and producers
of green technology.
It was initially started with
1.5 billion ringgits soft loan
and has now increased
to 3.5 billion ringgits.
The scheme offers a 2% interest
subsidy, and 60% of the loan
will be guaranteed
by the government.
From 2009 to November,
2014 351 projects
were covered by this scheme,
including 243 energy efficiency
projects, 17 green building
projects, 91 waste and water
projects.
The majority of projects
are located in Kuala Lumpur,
Selangor, and the Johor Bahru.
Most of projects focus
on electrical electronics
subsector, and the
biotechnology subsector.
Besides actions stipulated
from the ministry level,
we can also see some
progress at a regional level.
Iskander Malaysia is an
important economic corridor
in the southern part
of peninsula Malaysia.
It has recently begun
low carbon programs.
The Low Carbon Blueprint
Iskander Malaysia 2025
was endorsed by the product
minister of Malaysia
in the Summit 2012.
This blueprint was prepared
by a group of urban planners
and researchers.
Professor Ho Chin Siong from
University Technology Malaysia
is a main member of this team.
HO CHIN SIONG: I think
green technology policy
is a very important
policy, because you focus
on the use of green technology
in city building or city
planning.
So in our country here, we are
trying to use energy efficiency
technology.
We are trying to use
renewable energy technology,
and also recycling.
The solid waste management
office, urban planning
have to reconsider
how to promote
green technology, or green
energy, or green transport,
or green industry
in city planning.
So I think this
is the way forward
for our nation [INAUDIBLE]
TU FAN: Also Malaysia
has made progress
in promoting green technology.
Interviews with government
officials, researchers,
and industrial firms, shows that
many pieces as still missing.
First, information about green
technology and the policies
are still very limited.
I conducted a questionnaire
in 15 factories.
It shows that one of the main
barriers for industrial firms
to use green technology
is information.
TEH KEE SIN: The government
intention is good.
But sometimes the SME are
facing another challenges.
When it comes to the green
technology or green industries,
sometimes when we want to get
someone to justify that you are
in the green industries,
sometimes we cannot get
the right person, to confirm
and justify that we are in that
field.
Sometimes we may not be
able to get the [INAUDIBLE]
So this is another challenge
that we are facing.
HO CHIN SIONG: Some
of this information
may not have reached
other industrialists.
But I think the important part
is, actually, this information
have to be disseminated
to a bigger group.
And then I think
we strongly feel
that the chamber of commerce
industry association
should look closely,
also trying to get
to know more about this green--
I think the ministry themselves
do know.
They are trying ways and means
to disseminate this information
so that actually more and
more people have opportunity
to access to this
green tech plan.
TU FAN: Did you hear about
that green technology policy?
SPEAKER: What?
TU FAN: Green technology.
SPEAKER: I myself, I
like all these things.
Green energy, now maybe they
use more of these solar energy,
green energy.
I think these are the two main
things they are using now.
So solar energy-- actually,
I myself am using it.
Now they use it for
as a hobby, but later
on when I know more
about it, maybe
I will use it partially to
reduce my company's electricity
to replace other supplies
to cut down the cost.
TU FAN: Secondly,
there is a mismatch
between the needs of
the firms, and the focus
of government programs.
According to the questionnaire,
industrial firms priorities
were waste water, energy
utilization, solid waste,
energy supply, and
then green buildings.
However, most of the
government incentives
go to energy projects,
mostly for solar.
PRAKASH NAGALINGAM: We feel
that too much emphasis has
been given to solar,
and we are trying
to look into other areas
like thermal energy
and also the ocean
thermal energy which
will lead new energies as well.
Because initially the green
technology concentration
was only by the
federal government.
We didn't incorporate with
the state governments.
As you can see, the
green technology concept
is a federal concept.
But these [INAUDIBLE] encouraged
all the state governments
to have their own
green technology
concept in state level.
So once the state level has
their own green technology
concert, so this kind of
mission can be discussed more
in the particular states.
So then you can see,
now, I do agree with you,
the advantage is
pretty much low.
TU FAN: To improve the
wave implementation,
there is urgent need to have
a validation of the policy.
Until now, there
has no assessment
of the green technology
policy implementation.
PRAKASH NAGALINGAM:
They can do so much
in [INAUDIBLE]
investment, I mean
creating a scenario
for the investment,
for the green
technology players.
But then, as I can tell you that
we are not really sure how much
benefit [INAUDIBLE]
by these people,
and how much green technology
has contributed to the policies
of--
TU FAN: Adopting
green technology
will not be easy for
developing countries.
The most important reason
is that green technology
is a comparatively
expensive approach.
Even in developing
countries, we still
can see that the argument
about if government
should invest in
green technology.
But it is clear from the
experience from Malaysia
that government
incentives are still
very important to
encourage green technology.
PRAKASH NAGALINGAM: People say
that only developing countries,
I mean, concentrate too much
on subsidies and incentives,
but actually it's a
[INAUDIBLE] scenario.
Last time I went to
Holland, Netherlands.
As you can Netherlands is
a very developed country,
and they really pay much
attention to the environment.
The are very environment
friendly people.
But, they have, when
it comes to transport
industry, the
government, in 2013,
they came up with this
incentive for green,
I mean electric vehicles, and
also plug-in electric vehicles.
So when the incentive
was introduced in 2013,
the sales of EV rocketed.
And the highest sale [INAUDIBLE]
went to Mitsubishi Outlander.
It's known as PHEW.
It's actually a plug-in
hybrid, electric vehicle.
But when the incentive ended
by 31st December, 2013,
sales of electric
vehicles in Netherlands
dropped tremendously in 2014.
So as you can see, the lifestyle
of people, the consumers
are very much related to
incentives and subsidies.
TU FAN: Secondly, for
developing countries,
having consensus will be
equally critical for launching
green technology actions
across every area,
from construction, to
transportation, to industrial.
Malaysia has developed
incentive policies,
but local government needs to
be involved for that knowledge
to be diffused
across the country.
This is also an
important law for
other non-government
institutions
such as industrial associations.
The way the funding of SME
comes now, the funding of SME.
TEH KEE SIN: No,
we have no funding.
Yeah, we don't have
funding because we
should be self funded, I think.
So sometimes when we talk about
the funding for the R and D.
R and D is a long
term investment.
At the beginning stage you may
not be earning benefit at all.
So you have to come up
with a lot of resources.
For the green [INAUDIBLE]
or green industry
or even the [INAUDIBLE]
We still have
to-- the government [INAUDIBLE]
whether it be the [INAUDIBLE]
or whether it be the [INAUDIBLE]
the government should
take the lead.
[INAUDIBLE] in terms of
the green [INAUDIBLE]
green technology,
green industry,
we are still so much behind some
other countries in our region.
You know, Japan,
Taiwan or even China,
I think we are still
pretty much behind them.
So we hope [INAUDIBLE]
Also blaming some
of the ministry.
[INAUDIBLE] that never
[INAUDIBLE] That's why
[INAUDIBLE]
TU FAN: The size of government
support, both federal
and the local government,
and the cooperation
from associations, public
education and capacity
building for the labor
force are also important.
No matter how difficult
it is, people in Malaysia
have become aware that behavior
change is much important.
Without behavior change,
nothing will happen.
HO CHIN SIONG: We should
not only look at mitigation.
We have to look at adaptation.
Adaptation means,
we see that also we
have to how to adapt
to this climate change.
So mitigation can be expensive.
Adaptation should
come in together.
And I think the most
challenging part is
that mind change, the mindset.
How do you promote low carbon
society to the local society
so that they have the mind
change, the mindset changing
from very high consumption
to a low consumption society?
So by doing that they
could cut down their waste.
They could cut down
their consumption,
and they could actually
improve their quality of life,
even without having a
very high consumption.
So I think mindset
change is very important.
That's why in our
campaign we started,
we call it, low carbon society.
We didn't call it
low carbon city.
TU FAN: In developing countries,
the government and the citizens
are equally for ways
to grow economically,
but at the same time, protect
environment and mitigate
global climate challenges.
Critics of green
technology is that it's
a very expensive investment
for developing countries,
and that it's not easy
to get access and adopt
because of knowledge barriers.
From 2009, Malaysia
has taken steps
to implement green technology.
Each step has not been easy.
The Malaysia experience with
promoting green technology
can provide insights for
other developing and developed
countries.
[MUSIC PLAYING]